what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch
House of the Dragon episode 6 today John
how are you I am nervous and excited how
are you I am excited not nervous I have
utter Faith you know we're doing a time
Jump we're getting some new faces I'm
sure it's gonna be fine it'll be great I
have the utmost faith in this show so do
I uh ladies and gentlemen one thing I
want to mention really quick is if you
happen to see those like spam messages
going about of like hey bro you won
congratulations it's happened a lot of
YouTube channels I keep blocking as many
of these accounts as possible but they
keep creating new ones please do not
respond to them we've had a few
followers who have already like given
out contact information please do not do
it that is not us want to make that
clear uh secondly leave a like because I
just uh decided to look out for you guys
yeah so you deserve a pat on the back in
the form of an upvote yeah leave a like
And subscribe and click that
notification Bell to get notified when I
react for the next episode is out leave
your thoughts Down Below on what you
think of this particular one also full
interaction watch along as we sync up
with their own copy of House of the
Dragon available for super sexy Rejects
at our patreon page we cover several
shows over there exclusively with
reaction highlights and watch alongs
included thank you to all who have
joined us so far your support means the
world and lastly the team of prepper
thank you for helping us edit down these
highlights uh yeah I'm excited let's see
what's going on in today's episode
[Music]
mm-hmm
and again
[Music]
without modern medical practices
so much more unsettling
whether successful or unsuccessful
births in this shower
quite unsettling
[Music]
princess
what a reintroduction yeah what a moment
oh my god oh Christ
I'm taking myself
a bed princess yes I should help me
dress
[Laughter]
so creepy I know
I better talk about a Warner
a boy
yes hold on
oh like no connection oh my
God
seleno it is a privilege to be amongst
the first two congratulate you
I may be of any service
come my Lord
we got it from here John Malkovich has
to
obtain everything I know
[Music]
that's an impressive ass crane shot
all
princess
wow yeah you have an age today what was
that conversation last week
nonsense
what happy news this morning
he lives
just barely
we haven't still free
great name
yeah I do hope the labor was easy
I think I called the midwife
that's the renyra I know
soon I'll need to make it when he looks
like you
[Laughter]
[Music]
I think
me before you name my channel
he's our child is he not which means I
get to name him any one of us is
bleeding I deserve some saying the
Affairs of my own family
it seems interested in our first right
I was waiting for that
we chose an egg for the baby that looks
like the perfect one
and egg cheese the dragon pit princess I
thought at best there is baby
another boy I heard
oh my God it is there baby she got a
thing for her
her guards
[Music]
Young Chris Pratt
[Laughter]
once they're fully Bound to You they
will refuse to try construction for any
other
can I say it
[Music]
[Laughter]
is for Max
that pork you're the only one of us
without the dragon indeed so we found
one for you oh no behold the pink dress
the short amount of carefully first
flight's always rough
he's gonna take that pig and make it the
fiercest in the realm
[Music]
it's just gonna be a brothel of dragons
just laying eggs all over each other
foreign
[Music]
say the words
I just wanted to meet their eggs over
hatched
why is that you know why I'm afraid I
don't don't
I had a black mirror at once one day she
escaped her pasture
the neighboring stallion side of fall on
her
was born
the most unremarkable brown horse
nature is a thing of mysterious works
it's a very viscerous answer I am so
worried about what Allison's gonna do
yeah
yeah I'm afraid he will eventually
someday die and it's all gonna come out
the princess raniera is brazen and
Relentless a spider who stings and sucks
her prey dry spoiled
oh wow God
yes
Homeland yeah
whose idea is it
the pig
was it your plot
it was the two of them
I could be sure Emma does your brother
oh he said We are family out the new
will Ascend the throne into Sarah's
Targaryen would be her Heir your very
life could be forfeit
you are the challenge you are the
challenge aegon simply by living and
breathing
yeah
you are the King's first born son and
what they know holds everyone in the
realm knows in their blood and in their
bones
that one day you will be our King
's
scary
all these years Allison's been on the
same same anxiety real riddled mission
God what a curse it was to marry the
king
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
these guys have just been dealing with
this [ __ ] all these years
permanent residence here in pentos
this Mance I would give to you outright
we are Travelers we've already extended
our visit here
Mr Gemma softer
when we will suddenly entertain
so they must have really hit it off
after a rainer's wedding oh yeah
it's a good life here
welcomed and vetted and eternally
guessed precisely they are using us it's
refreshing isn't it
I want my child to be born where I was
born on drift mock at my end I want to
die a dragon Rider's death
[Laughter]
just when I thought he got way more
vulnerable you know like we're still
here
I'm done what are you
stopping your knees
feet life
this is the staff lineup my dude you're
turning into the Crypt Keeper
knock down then you get up again they're
never going to keep you down
weapons up boys
boys you mean Sons
children of mine question my method of
instructions sir
well I merely suggest that method be
applied to all your people very well I
will kill the Targaryen Lads eldest son
against eldest son
it's hardly a fair map I know you've
never seen true Battlestar but when
Steelers drawn a fair match isn't
something anyone should expect
okay surprise Kristen still has a job no
I'm surprised he's so chill right now
yeah
I'll deal with him this episode's
actually giving me season one Game of
Thrones Vibes yeah
he's really playing favorite this is
what you teach Cole
cruelty
the weaker opponent your interest in the
Princeton's training is quite unusual
Commander
have that kind of devotion toward a
cousin
or a brother
or a son
don't you're revealing your cards man
yeah dude you gotta gotta be Chiller
than that oh damn
Kirsten's getting a taste of his own
medicine from a few years ago
[ __ ]
he's so like bitter and angry and
envious hey
positively green the son of a steward he
is
you have laid US Open
the accusations
of an uglier treachery yeah dude
you're intimacy the princess Renee
renewable mean Exile and death
for her for the children
flimsy Shield alone stands between you
and the headsmen those babies don't look
black at all
I feel like you could have seen this
come
I have played my part here you do not
desert your post when the storm
the wise sailor flees the storm
as it Gathers
I really love this dialogue yeah and man
is everyone in pain in the show
that's your princess and the heir to the
throne you are commanded to remain in
King's Landing and at my side
let's try popping a real one yeah please
there's one real one I feel like you
guys really could have saved yourself so
many headaches some type of witch potion
an equivalent to a Viagra yeah there's
got to be something or a way to you know
just turkey baster
but if you wish to
wish to be your father would tell you
the same father ignores me
he's doing his best
I really like her she's the only one
with like a gracious heart yeah everyone
else is so emotionally retreated now
they've all had to compromise a great
cost of their own happiness
[Laughter]
that was that was a sick burn perhaps I
too I'm not the wife you would have
wished for yourself Elena
that made my piece
the man I married more than this
you two must go to the counseling of
couples
[Laughter]
next episode
Colin a maester
's looking
there would be country folk who know
where the lines have been drawn for
Generations
that is easy enough
[Laughter]
those actresses are really good yeah
it's a really impressive handoff
I have felt the strife
between our families of late my queen
but we are one house
long before that we were friends
we look like different people back then
my son jacaris will inherit the Iron
Throne after me I propose we betrothed
him to your daughter Helena
Ally ourselves
to finally getting along
the Dragon's egg is a handsome gift
I thank you for your offer and we will
consider it Julie you must rest now
husband
oh
Sarah's just once everyone to get alive
though and it's so terrible at making it
happen
we're a family
childish corals joined hands and be
stronger for it
As You Wish husband
when I am cold in my
framing God they are both Relentless
protective and desperate
Your Grace I feel
I have come to resign my position as
hand of the king what a man my son howim
has disgraced himself and every fish
wife in King's Landing will soon be
telling the Tale But there is a shadow
over my house and it grows ever dark I
can no longer serve you with integrity
yeah I don't know upstanding guy you you
have so much technique such a gluten
yes
oh my God Allison Jesus Christ
the one thing
you know it
you will continue in your service to the
crowd I would then ask leave to take my
son from court and the school came back
to the family seat at parano and will be
Lord of Heron's castle one day it is
time he assumed his duties there
oh it's so good
so good
it's like the master class Battle of
protection and political war games
this is so good
self-interest
at all I know
you're playing the old game man the game
is changing
you cannot say my queen that your father
would be would be partial in the end no
but he would be partial to me oh
in order
so theirs is the Hannah here's the his
brother is the one so everyone he was a
garden
oh
I'm prepared to offer you Mercy if
you're prepared to pay a little price
oh what
why why don't show it
oh wow
oh my God
I I almost closed both of them
cut away and you're just imply I can't
not
you must put now my lady
[Applause]
[Music]
it's the limit of my art
child will not come
the child refuses to be born here
couldn't lay open the womb
try to remove the infamous
by way of the blade
oh
that guys
no
[Music]
body
[Music]
[Music]
oh
wow
that Dragon really didn't want to do
that
yeah man loyal to one
I'll be a stranger
when we meet again
damn
Kristen you know how to push all the
right buttons
it's a long game of getting back at
somebody
never recovered from that [ __ ] in his
honor
[Music]
you are a Targaryen
matches
dude
Just Say Elena is your your father it's
a dragon stand me I should have left
years ago if you were absent from court
she would pour her honey in your
father's age
the wise sailor flees the storms it
Gathers
bring him
oh we'll need every sword we can master
bring Kieran Culkin along the gay lives
on
gay is okay at Dragonstone Hauser save
the cat moment yeah
save my husband's mistress boyfriend
foreign
something's gonna happen to him
oh
my God against his own brother this
world was so cruel
[Music]
oh that is
ridiculous what a treachery Jesus
up
oh man dude that other son is oh steak
and a half [ __ ] oh oh hell's gonna break
loose all seven of them
oh this is not gonna fly but I will
surrender what you should know
or they both die
[Music]
Queen makes away
not seven to the realm would not strive
to fulfill it
I assume new world rights to your father
oh
she did not
uh but that's how he gets you
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah yeah oh my God what a
like they're all sorted and twisted and
there's so many intersections between
personal and political and everything in
between and yet this one felt like the
most the most of all that like Jesus
so many twists of the knife
so many people burned alive
I don't trust my family anymore
yeah keep an eye on
you're gonna wake up in a locked room a
little bit on fire just any of them
they're always looking out for
themselves kill me in a heartbeat if I
meant they could gain some power I just
try to advise you free of personal gains
free of personal self-interest sir
oh my goodness gracious can't trust
anyone and you can't make and you can't
throw anything out there you don't
expect somebody to act upon
that was uh that was depressing as [ __ ]
that was
that was like so desolate and desperate
and yeah
and just as tense like they they're
really good at like once you get started
even the chiller scenes are still sort
of like your shoulders are up and you're
like I don't know I got a bad feeling
about this
yeah yeah that was really I was just
really it's like stepping into a void
I I think it's so well constructed
there's there's such a power to the
right opening scene I really believe in
you gotta nail that opening scene and
especially for such a Time jump and
almost like
it just reframes the construction of
like those previous episodes you know I
once or I think I think it was Vince
Gilligan who said there was there was a
some screenwriter once uh talked about
actually I think I heard from Dan Merle
who
quoting someone else and I was like oh
that's interesting about
um if you're writing a pilot you should
um you know write that pilot
and then write the second episode and
that second episode's your pilot and I
was like oh that's actually right that
is a great Revelation it's a great tip
it's a fantastic tip oh my God and then
stepping into this I was like you know
in some ways it sort of feels like this
was the first episode yes you know
obviously it wouldn't it wouldn't work
as well and you do need some additional
context to really keep up
um but in some ways it does feel like a
first episode to a series
um and then the other ones I love how
like this comes in the middle of it all
and then you have all that other
supporting episodes prior to help
Elevate this episode and it it's so
strong and I think this show has such a
great grasp on how to handle the
in-between with the time jumps because
all the strained relationships and all
the emotions that have been
percolating throughout that have just
been boiling over like you you have
someone like Allison what I love of the
parallel of drama with Allison and
renera is like Allison's so out to get
renera like she's so out to get her
standing so many times and we've seen
Allison to send to the the position of
Queen through Power of manipulation you
know even though we witnessed it happen
in a way where it didn't seem like she
really wanted it but her father you know
uh manipulated her into doing it to
force her to do it
and now that she's here she has embraced
the position of Queen she she is Queen
and more importantly she's a mother she
and she's a very protective mother
and and you got the same thing with
renera and they both just want to
protect their families their me their
their media families you know their
their next of kin and stuff
and then that's where so much of this
this Mind Games comes from and trying to
take each other down and stuff but it's
like how
I I always talk about like a big part of
plotting is you don't want to just see
plot unfold you really want to see what
will happen to characters
via the plot like how will what will
become of them what will change them and
I loved how like this whole episode
Allison uh played brilliantly by Olivia
Cook uh like Allison is is just so
headstrong and so determined and just
like try to cut through the [ __ ] and
I think that opening scene is so strong
of
the way they paint the light like you're
capturing it from rhaenyra's perspective
the show has pretty much put you in
renero's perspective as she is the
protagonist of the show and when she
gives birth this struggle and and then
immediately it's this like foreboding
ominous presence of like what is Allison
like now yeah and why does she want to
see this baby yeah what's going on nah
she just wants to make sure she's like
ain't black yeah looks nothing like that
guy go back try again I'm not gonna
recognize this air yeah such Mrs butts
is a [ __ ] baby
and uh because like
like Allison is is frustrating at the
same time I'm like well she's not wrong
yeah she gets to be and the thing that
this shows God of me to become
compassionate for her in an angle
because you don't want to see renero
taken down you don't want to see like
you that's the thing you don't want as
an audience member like I don't want to
see renera suffer
and yet Allison is not wrong about what
her Pursuit is of the truth she's trying
to expose yeah because she fears for the
life of her children dying yeah where
that's all according to the rules like
she has followed suit and she seems like
she's been faithful this entire time
like I was wondering you know does she
sleep or maybe the show will unveil that
she she does have some fun with someone
else on the side but the impression I
get is that she abides by the rules yeah
that she follows through and
and and it is like uh it's such it's so
well constructed how none of this is is
black and white and I love how it's just
all like just messed up these families
yeah so messed up yeah well you can and
you can feel how and why people act the
way they do even if it hurts or even if
you don't you know want yeah even if
you're rooting for one character or
another you can't help but see where
each one is coming from and I thought
like Allison has a really great and
fascinating Journey over this and and
all that groundwork they laid really
does hold up because yeah like that
ending beat where she finds out that um
that uh you know the the sun's strong
whatever that uh guy's name is with the
cane uh you know when she finds out
Loris there you go yeah she finds out
what he really did and you can tell like
oh this is probably her moment to cross
over to the other side of like oh now
I'm in some kind of disastrous
circumstance I didn't ask to be a part
of and I'm now in the game I feel like
part of what you get to watch characters
do is is either in indulge in or abstain
The Game of Thrones yeah and so now she
like it or not has been pulled into it
despite her best efforts and it's like
those foundations make so much sense
when you see like her father that last
scene she had with him after putting so
much faith in rhaenyra and then you see
the way they interact now Allison and
raniera interact and it's like you can
tell that deep deep deep deep down
there's that wish of like you know
there's that Bond we used to have it's
somewhere in there but I just can't
trust you anymore I can't put my faith
in you anymore no matter what game you
talk and you can feel the strain of the
history of the characters but also you
can really feel the immediacy like when
she has that scene with egg
had a wild scene with aegon where she
like grabs his face and is like no like
she might try and eliminate you like you
see the corners she's been pushed into
and I love that one bit she says because
I really felt it for her as much as you
know everybody has their opinion when
she says that thing of like nobody's I
don't have anybody in my corner like
nobody is lying on my behalf nobody is
is you know at least taking what I have
to say seriously and I really felt that
for her I was like I get it you know
you're in a very thankfulness position
and you're pretty much doing it alone
you know she is doing it alone yeah like
she doesn't have the support of her
husband not at all not at all he's like
I just want to get along that's
definitely uh that's definitely the
right child all three all those kids and
you feel like I don't see the black and
I feel like so much it it creates a
fascinating scenario because I'm like I
don't even think king viserys would need
to do like the full-on letter of the law
because everybody you know like part of
the charm of of these shows and part of
the truth of the matter is everybody
stands on the ceremony even though
everybody knows that to some degree or
another the ceremony is [ __ ] and
built on lies and uh and and uh yeah I
don't know there's there's I I lost my
train of thought
ceremony train of Lies yeah you know
it's it's it's
that thing of oh yeah if visiris had
even just I don't know had a straight
talk with her I feel like so much
trouble could be averted but it's his
like staunch adherence to nah I like he
he plays the willful ignorance really
well because you can tell he knows the
truth and you can also see him creating
lies for himself to believe and then
pass office well he has to believe it
because if he does if he doesn't believe
it that's condemnation for his daughter
yeah he has to Exile and kill her
because it's not like she just gets you
know she doesn't just get in trouble
she's dead yeah and then in a day he
does love her this so yeah that's uh I I
love the I love the dejected nature of
every every character portrait here
because everyone's so retreated and has
to live under a guise like all elephant
wants like personally my favorite
performance in this episode was was
Olivia Cook I thought she was very
gripping yeah and because she's so on
edge and it's just such a desperation
for truth and I do think who's playing
Emma Dar I got her name eleven Darcy I'm
a Darcy Darcy fantastic so internal yeah
and I I love a good in um
I love a good performance where you you
have to it's very physical and you have
to keep it together there's a truth
underneath the surface but you can't let
on like that whole beautiful shot where
she's
she it's the after birth
um uh situation she's got going on and
she's trying to walk through the halls
and and demonstrate character and
strength and be protective of her
newborn
and she's gotta like just not leave the
portrayal of blood in it but also not
look like She's suffering here and has
to it has to be strong and every scene
she has there's so much going on
underneath
her dialogue there's and the the
reactions that she's having towards
um oh my God totally blank on his name
there's a lot of names here people what
is the name of of the the husband who's
oh Elena lanor
um uh like every moment with lane or and
then lanor has just escaped into
uh a life of just he's just it's just
pure escapism for the guy debauchery
having fun messing around partying he's
like a college kid who can't get in
touch with his emotions you know yeah
like a dude who just went through the
worst heartbreak fight man yeah it's
like I love that the last episode was
that that Dreadful wedding moment where
they where everything fell apart for
them and truths for truths have been
coming out like
people know the truth but no but it's
just not public knowledge right now and
or something that we can't no one can
just talk about then you've you catch up
to here and you watch how everyone's
changed since that moment in time like
Kristen is so angry like he was such a
sweetheart he was so sweet he was like
the gentlest spirit and then here he's
so Allison and wants revenge like you
said playing the long game it it doesn't
even
it's like he doesn't strike when he's a
character who's who would say I I'm
seeking Revenge but it's going to be
coming out in all the most bitter
envious ways Possible Oh yeah and that
whole taunting and using the children as
a way to ring out the truth uh from uh
oh my god oh from uh uh
Harwin Harwin straw break bones yeah
from Harwin was was such a powerful
scene because it's they're using the
kids are the truth to the whole
situation yeah and and nothing is more
um evoke something so Primal and nothing
speaks more volumes of Truth than than
the defense of nature
one two you get to watch him play a
mirror almost to like moments he's had
in the past it's like he has that moment
with Allison where he's just like the
guilt is too much I need to say
something you know like he reveals
himself and he basically lures Harwin
into the same kind of situation and then
combines it with his little wedding
display it's just like yeah man you know
now you know how I feel you know break
it and wail on me for a minute and then
yeah expose yourself like play right
into my trap and then Damon is a
character who
you know you when you meet this
character he's someone who who seemed to
want it all
like he wanted it all and he's hidden
away from a lot of those desires now
it's uh it's obviously
there but it's it's it's like this
coldness has brewed over him which is
also allowed again for this great
fleshing out of character of
you know it's it's kind of like those
movies where you you got that and that
badass past character
kind of like uh I don't know I don't
know why this is the one that comes to
Mike it's not the best representation
but decently apt uh Bob odenker now
[ __ ] nobody okay that's the kind of
character is like I got a badass pass
and yeah I've had to push it away and
and I like my family yeah but there's
there is this other urge inside of me
but I I have to hide from it and even
though he hides from it it's it's led to
would look like a relationship where he
actually did love her sure and and the
that ugliness still managed to to
um
uh give me a word John uh to emerge and
yeah resurface trying to think of a word
as like grows like a virus
yeah yeah I guess that works yeah like
the seat back and it will relax into it
ugliness will over overtakes a situation
again and then led to the death of her
in a way that was so emote because I
really liked her and she was the one
with the most heart uh the mom I was
gonna say this was the episode where the
two characters who demonstrated the most
like genuine either hearts or just like
uh non-self-interested honor both got
flamed yeah in this episode everyone's
so many like little fingers here I know
everyone's a everyone's amateur little
finger Everyone's an amateur little
fingers a lot of against each other
because yeah you had this strong it's
interesting how you have
um
uh who was the okay there's Lionel
there's Laris and who's the who's the
dad
uh the hand yeah yeah yeah yeah uh where
is he fine no no no no no it is Lionel
Harwin
yes yeah the city watch and then yeah
Laris is is the uh conniving because
lionels seems to uphold the most
integrity
and and then you have
um Harwin who doesn't seem like a bad
guy like this is like a bad guy at all
but he does not follow through with the
rules and is committing an act that
could lead to some terrible things and
you gotta Learners who's just like
Sneezy and conniving yeah yeah it's easy
slimy yeah he and it just hit me that
that's the conversation that viserys has
with Lionel like a few episodes back
when he steps up to him and the series
is all drunk he's like I bet you want to
marry my daughter off to Sir break bones
your son blah blah blah he's like
fancy idea but no sir and and sure
enough it essentially happened even
though it's not really of his design and
then it leads to his death like that's a
great portent like a great ironic
foreshadowing
yeah ugh but yeah uh I feel like what
they do with Damon is is fascinating
because you expect such a you expect him
to be almost like a Joffrey at the
outset just because he has this sort of
wild and that's aegon
soon enough yeah but uh I don't know he
comes in with this very sort of almost
amoral just like I don't know he could
do anything at any time kind of feral
energy and now to watch him as he is
kind of like the most simmered down
version of that you're like you can tell
that that impulsive guy is still in
there but as you yeah contemplate just
like settling down and getting fat and
then also you know I love the the
unspoken notes like I feel like so much
of his actual character is never in the
dialogue because like their connection
kind of fascinated me there like it and
and to draw contrast from like the first
episode where it's like the series has
the back and forth with himself about
like what do I do do I cut the baby out
does the mom like you know uh and then
to watch Damon have to go through that
here but it felt so different and it
does feel like he cares and just can't
communicate that truly yeah like and uh
yeah like the way he he stumbles to the
beach just in time to watch her you know
be incinerated with their unborn child
like
I didn't even know her then it was
getting me so emotional it was such a
powerful moment and I was tearing up at
at that moment it's so powerful and it
like there's something very uh
connective and I think relatable of that
feeling of like I'm asking your own pet
to murder you yeah to put you out of
here like this is the way I gotta go
well like she said she said when she
died how'd she say she wanted to die I
was a battlefield or by fire I figured
she's a dragon Rider's death Dragon
Rider's death yeah yeah and and just
like the way they animated the dragon in
that moment of just this like I don't
you could feel what the dragon's
thinking like I don't understand no yeah
but I can't you're the only person I I
answer to you're my bonded writer I
can't do that yeah yeah and and she's
just pleading for it to happen
Damon I feel like the new Trope of Damon
is he's gonna have a well uh wife or
something who shows up one episode
you're like man I really like you you're
you're interested Oh no you're dead now
yeah you're gone but like it was so
heartbreaking because yeah they they
have that whole debate which felt very
real of like no I I want you know I want
our new next child to be born you know
in the house of my father I want the
kids to grow up there I want them to to
know their Birthright and now like all
of that goes up in Flames like literally
yeah it's like it's it's heart it's
heartbreaking and it also I don't know
and she also knows him well yeah it
seems though like you can pick he's he's
defensive because she's she's prodding
at truths you know of this guy who who
is he's denying what he really wants but
then he indulges himself with reading
about the Legacy Dragon Riders and stuff
the the kind you know he fancied himself
to to to ascend to yeah and he he blocks
it because it kind of get it because you
know like back home it's [ __ ]
nightmares this whole this whole
business is is such a horrible situation
for everyone no matter what rung of the
ladder you're on
yeah that's the main lesson I learned
from this show is never be involved in
ruling in statecraft because it's just
gonna destroy your life and your
morality and your morale again what I
really liking about this show especially
with like historical fantasy pieces it's
usually like good versus evil or there's
an outside force that threatens our main
characters or uh you know and in some
ways uh like like even with the crab
king crab king crab feeder feeder crab
king is SpongeBob uh with the crap
feeder
um but the craft feeder at the offset it
was seeming for people who haven't read
the book it was seeming like okay this
is the big bad or something like this is
the this is the threat to targaryens uh
and and no they they do away with that
and again the threat is everything
internal everything is like it's the
thing that is going to bring a crumbling
to the legacy is not and maybe I'm wrong
but this is the way the show seems to be
painting it is that it's gonna be all
within and not not because people
attacked it we're like we're taking
King's Landing yeah yeah no it's all
just lies and truths placed in in
inopportune and opportune places yeah
you're just watching yeah as as lies get
worse and truths come at inappropriate
or uh not inappropriate I guess there's
never bad time for truth but yeah I feel
like horrifically inopportune moments
and it's it's
really uh the journey that I mentioned
again what I brought at the beginning of
this talk was like the plot is so
interesting to unfold
but I'm so intrigued to see like what
dark depths are characters like Allison
and renera gonna descend to as the more
this goes on I'm so worried about both
because there's a thing with Allison
like as Disturbed as she is by the
revelation of the truth of what happened
to the strongs uh it's and I like to
some symbolism of the strongest
but but
but the how Disturbed she was by that
Revelation you're like who's only gonna
get worse for you man you're gonna have
to do worship yeah you're gonna be happy
to learn about this piece of information
you're going to turn into Lady Macbeth
yeah because I mean now now you've got
blood on your own hands and now you
can't you know cling to the fact that
you've always tried to you know do
everything by the book and stand on the
ceremonies and you have I forgot his
name again I'm John I'm sorry what's the
husband's name lanor Lenore with Lenor
he I you I worry about the way he
behaves because he seems to lack such
because as much has been like I'm
committed I've done everything for my
10-year plan I'm owed there seems to be
this he's going to slip up and he's
going to get himself caught and exposed
and you know yeah he doesn't seem like
he lays low or or does anything with any
level of secrecy yeah there's a bit of
this childish quality to him yeah yeah
that remains yeah he he kind of has an
entitled sort of obliviousness not like
a devious
um uh borderline maniacal nature in the
way of how Damon is no quite the
opposite you know you're like no you're
gonna like slip up and do something
that's going to get you all in trouble
you're gonna get caught you're you're
not helping the situation and it's not
this isn't a gripe but I do want to ring
both their necks like guys you you there
must have been a way for you guys to at
least have one child together at least
you had to know this was gonna turn into
a complete disaster I thought that's
what they were gonna do I thought that's
what they were I think that's why I was
like wait you gotta have a kid I guess I
can just force it nothing oh sure I mean
I'm I'm sure there are plenty of you
know throughout history there are
probably plenty of of men who are forced
into you know hetero marriages and had
kids you know it's definitely possible
but yeah I was like I'm sitting here
going man
I feel like you guys could have been a
little smarter about this like I feel
like you could again have a couple
bastards but but get one yeah they just
needed one because also too like you
know no you're in the position where
it's like of course people are going to
notice unfortunately because you know
you are of such different lineage
well there's a whole plot line about it
in my Me Myself and I were
it's good that's what they probably Drew
inspiration for epic
that's why it's so funny yeah have you
seen that movie
uh not in its entirety now I've seen a
couple of the very very well-known
moments his wife cheats on him okay in
the beginning with a black guy oh no and
gives birth to like triplets
before like they're all like completely
black
and
he just doesn't register like that's not
his kids
of course yes yes yes of course I like
it
I'm like let's come on it's so obvious
look there look at all that's gonna be
the problem it's the biggest dead
giveaway I was like if we one thing if
they were white and maybe you could get
away with some [ __ ] but the fact
that like uh the eyes look off or
something but I'm like no no I mean
there's a whole other aspect to this
that we are not talking about yeah mixed
race babies are are yeah you could
they're mixed race babies you could tell
when that's happened I'm surprised I
don't even say that in the show I know
I'm like maybe in the book I I don't
know if in the book If the characters
are
um uh like black folks I don't know yeah
is there like another word before black
people back then I I don't know that's
not a racist word but an actual like
historical work or something yeah yeah
yeah some uh George RR Martin word uh
Africa so
but anyway yeah I I would be I'm
surprised I don't
no one's bringing up the skin tone I'm
like that's the biggest dead giveaway
guys I mean yeah they have that whole
horse horse's conversation and even that
right yeah I was like dude but Sarah's I
appreciate you and we probably didn't
know as much about animals at the time
but it's not quite the same
you know like like yeah and like you can
have a cat give a litter and all the lit
all the cats are different colors and
[ __ ] but like I don't know it's a little
different when you got two humans and
you do your little Jean splicing
tic-tac-toe there's a skit to be made
about this whole discussion James Corden
Bring It On do it make it happen Gordon
get a wig in some costumes and do it
but yeah man this player is just so
white that it overshadows yeah that's
why they have to spoon that hair yeah
or yeah like canceling it out
straight brown hair
that's the I guess the deadest giveaway
is they're both so blonde yeah and
neither none of their kids
they're both really blunted
and it's so true and it seems like in
the Targaryen Clan you know the the the
blonde hair jeans are usually blonde is
a recessive gene scientifically but in
the Targaryen and the Valero Valerian
you know lineage it seems pretty
dominant yeah yeah well I mean even
Allison is the she's a Hightower right
Allison Hightower yeah and she she's
brunette and uh her kids are are way
blonde yeah they're not even like dirty
blonde
are just as Blonde as they get there I
do speaking of light right there like
like you've got so much working against
you guys and at least even if you
weren't smart on the first kid at least
by the second one be like we need a
blonde baby at least a blonde baby it
would be nice if the baby was also a
mixed race racial background because
then that would be the yeah I could
totally like I've seen it where like we
we know um
the Henry's yeah you know like that
everyone kind of
had like they they were all like
dark olive skin
brown hair brown eyes and then there's
David
and like blue eyes and he's like I don't
know this happened but it is
but three in a row with these guys three
in a row they all look pretty similar to
each other yeah that's why that's why uh
Damon's just like blunt I'm sarcasm line
yeah because the king pointed out how it
looks a lot like Harwin straw this is so
funny he's just like yeah they do
oh it hurts so bad even the kids can
pick up on it even Damon knows that he
ain't been back in Forever
yeah oh and that's the thing I don't
know that that's that's the fascinating
part is yeah watching all of this
structure and then watching Everybody
Talk the truth underneath it you know
yeah man well yeah it's great [ __ ]
um you can talk forever about this thank
you all for being here
um be sure to
uh leave your thoughts down below and
let's send this with shout out some
patrons thank you all
Zachary Barker you're sharper Irfan Chow
jury
Yuri my type I you're cool I like you
Taki wakimaki Ian Neil Simon's
California sweets song High Glover
you're made of rubber Jacob Neptune your
gold like doubloons NMB you're so silly
it never stops with fan Pops I pick up
my phone when it rings from Alan Ling
Logan profile pic looks kind of like
Barry kogan Burton no need to fear you
Akira I am drawn to aircons 39 times
over KUSI KUSI you make my my cheek so
Mushy Mushy bear in the garage you're a
flare amid the barrage of you stand out
I create a hex around my heart for Nick
X Juan Longoria Never Gonna bore ya you
never make me feel like I fail when I
hang out with Miss Ferguson AKA Gail
you're such a haughty Muhammad
al-sharani Jaren wanner you're as strong
as Bruce Banner Cliff Rodriguez better
do what he says it's gonna be okay when
you're around Alex Day master tenebrae
movie title John the goat makes me feel
warm like a big hot coat always a slam
dunk when you're playing with Andy Funk
Lorenzo Baxter pump it faster the rain
in Spain falls differently saying on the
plane don't ever try to kill Marco tunn
still I never have to force myself to
want to hang out with Lauren American
Horse there's a rhyme in there somewhere
if you find it my home was raided by
simply faded with my mom he corroborated
Ooey the things you do to me Joanna St
Louis he he there's a smell in the
debris I think it's Rogue Cree sour
jellyfish 94. don't get me started on
all the farting by Justin Martin Rosie
never nosy Beatty no Haiti calling you
got me bawling when I see you hanging
out with Joseph Stalin Philip Jughead
Smith Jr I feel my body's with when I
see Gents Smith
because she's so in shape and it makes
me feel fat by comparison honk honk for
Melanie LeBlanc if you support
Melanie we support you TJ track US
with uh habakkus habakkus definitely
it's a sauce yeah
I love a good TJ habakkuk sauce anyway
guys thanks so much for being part of
our patreon page and uh your support is
undeniable because it's there's evidence
it's here yeah it's evidence
so thank you
[Music]